[Music]
you've seen bazlerman take a fast and
loose approach to shakespeare the great
gatsby and a friends
[Applause]
[Music]
so when warner brothers asked him to
make a big elvis biopic he said rightio
20 music videos stick together by a bug
monster how about a dojo cat song in
there as well too late already in fast
hands
elvis
[Music]
before he slips into sting's metal
underpants in two austin butler delivers
a breakout performance as the original
quirked up white boy goated with the
sauce but don't get me wrong this
nickelodeon kid is all grown up all
right all right
hey you want to fish taco he can see
he can dance and he can flash the most
powerful doomy eye since nala gave the
green light to simba
[Music]
hey elvis you gotta cool it bro i'm
trying to do a trailer here
okay okay maybe just one little kiss
me colonel tom
what the [ __ ] is that i was just a boy
from huntington west virginia is that
tom hanks
meet colonel tom parker a monster who
should be banished to the uncanny valley
he crawled out of he looks like someone
left colin farrell's penguin on a hot
radiator and sounds like i don't know
wado making fun of the trade federation
it's somehow offensive to everyone there
was that fairytale wedding and uh
honeymoon on frank sinatra's jet
especially to the guy who actually
prepped for his role watch this carny
swindler never let the truth get in the
way of a good story sand the edges off
elvis to make him more palatable and
snow job the audience with a shallow
spectacle while milking them and elvis
for every penny oh so it's a baslerman
biopic too got it got it
are you an elvis historian kick rocks
daddy oh cause this retelling of the
king's life skips the iconic msg concert
infamous meeting with nixon and the time
he died on the toilet but if you're a
historian of music movie cliches get
ready to walk hard through all the
greatest hits like nervous first
performance with mike feedback
get a haircut
a rising up the charts montage
the hey kid try some drugs moment why
don't you try one of these put the pet
back in your step even the supportive
wife who stood by the artist since the
beginning though they leave out the fact
that she was 14 years old when they met
dude and i thought his relationship with
mama was weird i will call you every
night
you promise me
so if you're ready for the story of a
beautiful naive royal who just wants to
be part of their world with a powerful
voice that gets stolen by a big evil con
artist and someone marries a teenager
but you're also too racist to believe
that a mermaid could be black then this
is the live-action film for you he's
white he's white he's white
though to keep the analogy going brazil
would have to stab the kernel in the
chest with a boat at the end but
honestly that would've been out of place
in this movie cause it's bonkers
[Music]
[Music]
starring
eminem origins colonel slanders barely
even close to approaching legal a little
less conversation a little more action
my boy
my boy my boy my boy my boy my boy my
boy my boy my boy my boy my boy my boy
my boy my boy my boy my boy my boy
my boy
when army hammer's date spills a little
soy sauce on her arm
and all the crotch shots well that's my
dick mama
that's my dick too
but that's
[Music]
featuring the music of elvis
elvis nick is here hi everybody hi
doctor nick
ah thank you
thank you very much
head on apply directly to the forehead
good night cow good night moon cow
jumping over the moon mecca like a high
make a hiney honey hoe
yes my name finally got mentioned before
the trailer